you speak of green et arnaud economic
growth et que si tout ce que nous sommes
et mondial sur le climat en pologne la
jeune suédoise greta thoune berg a
accusé les dirigeants politiques de
faiblesse et d'inconscience son discours
a fait boule de neige et on les esprits
l'adolescente a aussi lancé un appel à
une grève mondial des écoliers pour
alerter les décideurs sur l'urgence
d'agir pour sauver la planète en europe
en australie
d'autres jeunes leaders étudiants ont
aussi plus la parole y organiser des
marches pour le climat au cours des
dernières semaines
au canada des adolescentes également
tenu des manifestations à ottawa et
vancouver
cette militante de 16 ans reproche au
canada de ne rien faire de concret pour
atteindre les objectifs mondiaux de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre ce
qui m'inquiète c'est que tous ces
événements là dont on entend parler tous
les jours parce qu'aujourd'hui les
médias ont parlé on en parle et en fait
on n'a pas tellement que ça nous
inquiète même plus et c'est ça en fait
qui est inquiétant c'est qu'on se dit
mais qu'est ce qu'il faut pour qu'enfin
ans réagissent au québec des étudiants
de l'université de montréal ont décidé
il y a quelques jours de lancer un
mouvement de sensibilisation
ce mouvement semble attirer de plus en
plus de jeunes ses organisateurs lançons
un appel à tous les étudiants de la
province vendredi on va les rejoindre
tous les cegep on est des gens
communication avec plusieurs personnes
des associations étudiantes du cégep à
travers à travers la province
les étudiants montréalais ont un message
pour le gouvernement québécois
on a l'impression que le gouvernement
élu de françois legault n'a pas
l'intention d'appuyer sur l'accélérateur
donc c'est pour ça que nous on est là la
société civile et c'était universitaire
bon l'encourager gentiment à appuyer sur
l'accélérateur
le groupe souhaite relayer l'appel lancé
pour une journée de grève mondial des
étudiants le 15 mars prochain
c'est un moyen de pression je trouve
qu'il ya peine ça m'a fait ses preuves
par le passé fait comme ça je pense
rarement en accord avec ça mais
l'environnement c'est effectivement un
enjeu important constaté c'est très
important pour moi dans la future
profession de l'art aller en grève pour
ce n'est sa main les débats des
étudiants sur leur rôle dans la lutte
contre les changements climatiques ne
font que commencer
sylvain desjardins radio canada montréal